so today we're delighted to have
actually it's a twofer and the hard
thing to imagine is we're going to
assessment and treatment in one fell
swoop dr. Thomas is going to start with
assessment I'm going to do it a little
bit about treatment this will be
something we'll come back to it's a bit
of a challenge as you'll see from
actually both assessment and treatment
we talked in autism about and Asperger's
and related disorders we're talking
about a broad range of issues we're
talking about little kids we're talking
about older kids we're talking about
kids with a very severe cognitive
impairment and two kids who a much
brighter than most of us so it's a real
it's an interesting set of challenges on
both scores and Cathy's going to start
off with assessment right so in this
session my main goal is to provide you
with an overview of what's involved in
assessment of autism spectrum disorders
I have 45 minutes to cover the topic so
bear with me if I start to speed up as I
talk but what I wanted to do was just
orient us to start and say something
about the terminology I'm going to use
and so we're talking about a class of
disorders autism and related disorders
in the terminology we typically use in
our diagnostic manual is pervasive
developmental disorders more and more in
the community among laypeople and then
also among professionals we've moved to
the language of autism spectrum
disorders so you may find that I'm using
them interchangeably throughout this
session now the interesting thing about
autism spectrum disorders at this time
is that there is no lab tests or medical
tests that we use to diagnose the
condition so there's no medical or
genetic or blood test or even neuro
imaging diagnostic measure rather the
diagnosis is based on behavioral
features so how the child presents and
what their clinical history is and there
are three main areas that we're looking
at in terms of the behavioral features
and just to refresh your memory about
those one is reciprocal social
interaction the other is communication
and the third is restricted and
repetitive behaviors and I'm not going
to go into these in detail but just want
to remind you of these three areas is
the main areas that are the features
we're looking at in terms of pervasive
developmental disorders more than this
with
in each of the domains there are a
number of specific features that we're
looking at so let's take for example
that social domain the kinds of features
we're thinking of as we think about
diagnosis include things like the
child's nonverbal behaviors eye contact
body postures and facial expression
whether or not they seek out other
people to share their enjoyment or
whether they elicit interactions from
other people so they're the bottom line
being that there are a number of
different features that go into that
domain alone and then if we take the
communication domain there are a number
of features that also present in that
domain whether the person has a delay in
language or if language does develop
they might have difficulty especially in
the higher functioning individuals they
have difficulty initiating or sustaining
a conversation or having a back and
forth conversation or we may find that
the person uses scripted language where
they're repeating over and again lines
from cartoon and then the third category
also comprises a number of different
features motor stereotype ease like
flapping for example or rocking
repetitive behaviors with person lines
up blocks or cars in a row very narrow
or circumscribed interest in a
particular topic like a deep fat fryers
for example as a idiosyncratic one and
then of various rituals routines or
preoccupation with parts of objects like
flicking of a doll's eyes rather than
using it in a more symbolic way the
reason I lay all of this out as we go on
to talk about diagnosis and assessment
is to bring up the point that when we're
talking about autism spectrum disorders
we're talking about three different
critical domains social communication
and restricted repetitive behaviors and
within each of those domains are a
number of different features and the
number the level of severity the
combination of the features can differ
from child to child so we want to be
able to both capture that the symptoms
or the features of the disorder but we
also want to be able to capture that
variability and that's where the
assessment process comes in so just
before we get into what's involved in
diagnosis and assessment let's talk
about one way of distinguishing the two
were thinking about the two so one
question that may come up is why do we
diagnose at all what's the importance of
a set of diagnosis and
what's involved in diagnosis I would
consider diagnosis one part of the
assessment process and we can think of
it in terms of that part of the process
that's about classification where we're
taking a constellation of behaviors or
features and we're grouping them in some
way they we find that they tend to hang
together and they're consistent with a
particular syndrome and not that
disorder that syndrome might be autism
it might be Asperger disorder and so on
and what we want to be careful about is
drawing a distinction between diagnosis
and having that diagnosis and the person
with the diagnosis so we're careful in
our language to talk about a child with
autism rather than an autistic child and
the main point there is that the
diagnosis is meant to capture only one
part of that child some and it's about a
group of features or behaviors that that
child is displaying it's not meant to
capture the whole of who that child is
now there are some very practical
reasons as well why we diagnose and some
of those include the implications for
intervention as well as legal rights in
terms of access to different services it
can also inform us about prognosis and
it also provides a common language for
different professionals to communicate
amongst each other and then also a
common language for individuals and
families until you notice and diagnosis
I have the disorders in different boxes
when we're talking about assessment
where I think of diagnosis as a process
of classification and here we're taking
these features and we're grouping them
together and we're saying this
represents a disorder called autism this
represents a disorder called Asperger
syndrome when we think about assessment
it's less about classification or that
general box that these things fit into
and more about the individual person and
trying to capture that variability that
I was talking about so here with
assessment we want to capture it in a
more refined in a more detailed way the
person's particular strengths and
weaknesses so I'm and that's an
important point as well we're interested
not only in where they're vulnerable but
also what their strengths are so I have
here an autobiographical statement
because I think what's really nice for
me about this particular statement is it
not only captures the disability but it
also gives you a flavor of the person
and that's always the balance that we're
trying to achieve so here this is from
Robert and that's not the persons that's
not the person's actual name but this is
my name is Robert I am an intelligent
unsociable but adaptable person I would
like to dispel any untrue rumors about
me I cannot fly I cannot use telekinesis
my brain is not large enough to destroy
the entire world when unfolded I did not
teach my long-haired guinea pig Kronos
to eat everything in sight that is the
nature of the long-haired guinea pig so
the point here is that we're diagnosis
is about classification assessment we're
trying to get a sense of who this person
what this person strengths and
weaknesses are and how the disorder
impacts them and we collect that
information through observation through
talking to people in the person's life
as well as the world of that individual
the last point I want to make is that we
consider diagnosis and assessment as the
first step toward treatment planning so
this is also the second half of this
talk is about treatment and there's a
reason why we have this the two
coordinated and that is that the
diagnosis and assessment process is
really that first step toward thinking
about treatment planning and so we try
to have intervention proceed from a
comprehensive picture of what the
person's problems and symptoms are but
also the challenges that are interfering
with their functioning and then in
addition the strengths that we can use
to help in their areas of weakness okay
the approach we take to assessment is
quite comprehensive and in part by
necessity when it comes to autism
spectrum disorders so the this
assessment model or this approach to
comprehensive assessment involves a
number of different elements and the mo
elements include a multidisciplinary
team assessing multiple areas of
functioning and collecting information
across a variety of settings and our
goal in all of this is to try to provide
a single coherent view of the person or
the individual with ASD one that we can
effectively communicate to other people
who are working or living with this
person and then also drawing a
connection between our results or our
findings and appropriate recommendations
and goals and strategies for
intervention so what I want to focus on
first are the three points in blue
talk a little bit more about them the
assessment of individuals with autism
spectrum disorders calls on the
expertise of a wide variety of
disciplines and these include but are
not limited to child and adolescent
psychologists and psychiatrists social
workers speech and language pathologists
occupational physical therapists as well
as people from the medical field and
call it including neurologists
geneticists pediatricians particularly
when it comes to first detection or
first initial identifying those initial
red flags can also include behavioral
therapists and others the involvement of
this wide range of professional speaks
to the presentation of the disorder in
and of itself and when you think back to
that first slide of all the different
domains of functioning that are involved
we see that this is a disorder that can
impact multiple areas of in development
and so involves multiple professionals
and the assessment involves multiple
areas of functioning so in addition to
having these different professionals
involved in in the assessment process
there are also different areas of the
person's functioning that we want to
capture and this includes a
developmental history their cognitive or
level developmental functioning
diagnostic assessment speech and
language assessment of sensory motor
skills medical and so on alright then
the third part I think that's part of
this comprehensive model is recognizing
that the child or the adult or
adolescent with ASD operates or
functions in a variety of different
settings so there are a number of
different settings in which they are
learning and interacting with others
playing or working and as it would be
true for most of us the children or the
individuals with ASD may present
differently in those different areas so
if you think of yourself at home versus
how you present at school versus how you
present at work versus how you function
in a different set in these different
settings that there can be some
variability and that would be true for
individuals with ASD in addition the
settings themselves can vary so the
settings may differ school versus
home versus community may differ in
terms of how familiar it is to the
person with ASD may differ in terms of
the level of structure that's offered
the level of interpersonal support as
well as how complex the demands are in
that environment so as part of the
assessment process we want to also
capture that variability and we want to
we're not interested only in a snapshot
of the child at this point in time as we
when we see them in clinic for the day
or two days or three days that their
valuation takes place but we want to
have a sense of how they present across
different contexts and with different
people and this information can be
important and relevant both in terms of
how the child presents in a consistent
way across these different these
different settings but also if there are
differences in how they present and the
differences in some ways can be almost
more interesting and more valuable than
the similarities and it's not meant to
say that the child is doing better at
home than at school are doing better at
school than home but it really gives us
a clue to what variables in the
environment or what variables in the
people who are working with the child
might be contributing or maximizing
their performance or their success in
that environment and so we may find that
we need it lets us know that we need to
increase the level of structure or we
need to increase the amount of routine
in their day or increase the number of
visual supports and so on so it all
becomes information that informs the
assessment the last thing that we do and
we think is an important part of the
assessment is include having a rule for
parent observation and again we're
mindful that in this setting in a
clinical setting we again have just a
snapshot of that child where we're
seeing them at this point in time over
two days in this somewhat artificial
setting and so the other thing that we
do is ask parents or invite parents to
observe the assessment and the value of
that is one recognizing that the parent
is an expert on their child and so this
gives us an opportunity not only to have
a common set of observations where we
can share what we've observed with the
parent and comment on that through the
feed brock feedback process but also
whereby the parent can tell us the ways
in which the child is present
similarly or different than other
settings they've seen them in and again
that becomes really important
information for us for example sometimes
one of the things that happens quite
frequently is that as part of our
standardized measures we ask the
children questions in a very particular
way and parents will say well he would
know the answer if only you asked it
this way that's really important
information for us because it tells us
on the one hand that the child has that
knowledge but that they need certain
cues or structures in order to elicit it
and so one of the goals that my issue
from something like that is a goal for
generalization or expanding the ways in
which they can access that information
all right so we've talked a little bit
about diagnosis and assessment as
capturing both the features of the
disorder and the variability and what I
want to turn to next is the different
aspects of the assessment itself and so
I'm going to touch upon these these
areas here and then and then talk about
differential diagnosis before we wrap up
okay in terms of the history historical
information includes developmental
history behavioral history educational
family history and history of treatment
and interventions again going back to
that idea that we have a snapshot we're
getting a snapshot of this child we're
seeing them at this one point in time
one of the things we want to do is
gather information about all the time
that preceded this visit so getting a
sense of all of the other the
developmental history of the child and
all the other information that surrounds
that child to this point in time the
historical information can be
particularly important in terms of
identifying were there any delays in
this child's development for example
when did first words first emerge are
there any atypical patterns of
development so things that we wouldn't
typically see in we wouldn't see in
typical development that this child has
has shown or is showing are there any
medical or genetic findings that would
be relevant to how this child is
presenting and are there any skills that
the child once had the
had gained and then lost all of this
information goes together and is
informative as concerns the diagnosis
and the differential diagnosis and we
collect this information through a
variety of means it can be through
clinical interview we also will collect
records so any of the past evaluations
that that were conducted for this child
will be part of the clinical record and
then at times will also invite video
recordings of the child early
development particularly if there's
concern about regression so if it's come
up that the child once had some skills
and has lost them and looks very
different than they had when early on in
development we might ask for video
recordings of times birthdays or other
family gatherings to see what the child
looked like at that point in time in
terms of their cognitive assessment the
cognitive evaluation or developmental
evaluation for younger children provides
an opportunity to obtain a measure of
the individual's overall intellectual
level or their overall developmental
level one of the things to keep in mind
is when we're talking about cognitive
functioning or intelligence it it
actually involves a variety of different
domains of functioning so what can go
into an overall measure of a child's
cognitive development or intellectual
development are measures of their verbal
knowledge and verbal reasoning their
nonverbal reasoning their memory
processes speed of processing visual and
auditory processing and so on so it's
actually not a unitary construct in that
context what's really interesting about
that and one of the most interesting
aspects of working with children with
autism spectrum disorders and conducting
these kinds of evaluations is the
variability in their presentation as
well this includes both the level of
cognitive functioning and also the
profiles of cognitive functioning and
and these have very specific
implications for how we select our tests
how we interpret them and what it means
for intervention so let's talk a moment
about levels of cognitive functioning
and this figure shows the normal curve
which I think most of you have probably
seen before and the main points for us
are that
mien is a hundred and standard deviation
is 15 and what that implies is that the
average range is 85 to 115 for
individuals with intellectual disability
or what was called in the past mental
retardation a score of under 70 which
would put you put place you in that
category of an intellectual disability
in terms of level of functioning what's
fascinating about talking about this
disorder even though we have this unit
or unitary disorder called autism or
autism spectrum disorders the range of
intellectual ability is extremely wide
it ranges from profoundly to severely
intellectually disabled all the way up
to these upper extreme ranges so even
though we have this one kind of one
classification and one disorder we see
tremendous variability in terms of the
levels of functioning and in the past
report suggested that about seventy to
seventy-five percent so almost
three-quarters of individuals with
autism actually functioned in the
intellectually disabled range as the
classification has broadened we find
that it's closer to about 55 percent who
are functioning in the intellectually
disabled range and about 45% of
individuals who are in the below average
average range and above average range of
functioning so in addition to levels of
functioning that can vary and have this
there this wide range we also find that
there's tremendous scatter within this
domain as well so that there are
profiles of strengths and weakness and
before I get into the details of these
numbers just to show you graphically and
you don't need to to know the details of
this other than to look at for example
that green line which stands out the
most you can see the tremendous peaks
and valleys this represents the average
performance of a group of individuals
for example for the Green Line it
represents individuals with
high-functioning autism on one cognitive
measure it's called the Wechsler
intelligence scale for children and you
can see on this one measure
unlike the typically developing
individuals who show a more flat profile
huge peaks and valleys in the
performance and this is not at all
infrequent and
terms of kids with ASD so give you gives
you a sense of not only the range in
terms of level of functioning but also
the tremendous range the highly
discrepant abilities and disabilities
that can be shown by individual child
this level of variability requires us to
be extremely cognizant of at least three
things and I'll touch upon those three
the first is we have to be really
careful about how we interpret our
global scores so for example here's a
child with a full scale IQ so that would
represent the global score of 102 that's
almost dead average if we were to say
that this child was functioning in the
average range we would lose a ton of
information about this child's cognitive
profile and here you see these different
domains that went into the full scale IQ
one is verbal the other is non verbal
working memory and then speed of
processing and the scores range from 65
to 126 range from well below average to
well above average the idea here is that
we don't want to lose that variability
and we don't want to interpret this IQ
score in isolation we really want to be
able to capture what those strengths and
weaknesses are alright the other thing I
want to mention I'm not going to go over
these different tests in detail except
to say that we also in addition to there
being variability in terms of the levels
of functioning and profiles of
functioning in the individual with ASD
there's also very various kinds of
measures to assess cognitive functioning
these are some of the common test
batteries we have nonverbal measures and
developmental assessments all of these
test batteries so even taking the top
group all of these measure overall
intellectual or overall cognitive
ability but what's interesting is that
they may measure it in very different
ways so what we find is not only are
there discrepancies discrepant abilities
in the child with ASD but there are also
differences in the way tests measure
cognitive ability and they can differ
along these lines the level of language
skills that are required of that person
taking the test the degree of complexity
of the instructions
level of structure that's provided for
example how much teaching is allowed on
the test items the the extent of the
social demand so how much interaction
there is when the person has to complete
the item whether or not time tasks are
used and how much motor involvement
there is so it becomes incumbent upon
the person who's selecting and
administering the test as well as
consumers of the information to have an
understanding of how these tests differ
because you can imagine that given the
discrepancy and abilities and then given
the various ways in which cognition can
be measured you can optimize or diminish
a person's performance based on the the
kind of measure that you select the
other thing I want to mention in this
context in addition to thinking
carefully about the scores that are
yielded by these measures we also want
to be careful about integrating our
observations with the test results so
the numbers are important but they're
not the end of the story in some ways
they're only the beginning and our
observations can be as important if not
more important in some cases we want to
integrate our observations with the test
result and to give you a very concrete
example I'm going to ask you to to do a
little exercise with me there's a
measure this is not part of a IQ test
this is a measure in a different kind of
battery and it's called category fluency
and you might have played a game kind of
similar that like it's similar to this
and the category here is animals and
what I want you to do is think about I
give you a certain amount of time like
60 seconds and I want you to name as
many animals as you can think of in that
time so what's the first animal that
came to mind for just shut one out dog
raccoon cat right those are the first
that would be typical most of a dog cat
horse raccoon bear and so on so here's a
young girl with Asperger's syndrome and
here was her first response sulphur
crested cockatoo Chesapeake Bay
Retriever hognose Viper
desert tortoise and so on it almost
became a test for me to see if I how
quickly I could write down all of these
responses what's interesting about this
is that of course you performed in the
average range and probably even above
average on
particular measure but to talk about
only that we lose again lose a lot of
information we really want to think
about that the content and our
observations as well and here the types
of responses she gave are interesting
both in terms of hinting at maybe what
was a special interest for her animals
and also think hinting at what might
separate her from her peers where most
of us and you would think most
seven-year-old girls might think about
horses as the animal that first comes to
mind for her the animal that first comes
to mind is a self requested cockatoo and
while animals is a lovely topic for kind
of shared enjoy shared interest among
seven year old girls if you're kind of
areas of special interests are are these
very specific animals it could actually
serve to to separate rather than unite
her with her peers all right the final
major points I want to make about the
cognitive assessment are are their role
in the evaluation and their implications
for treatment first in terms of its role
in the evaluation overall the cognitive
or the developmental assessment is a way
of framing the evaluation if we know
something about the child's overall
level of ability it helps us interpret
their behavior in other domains so here
is an example again of somebody who's
got extremely good nonverbal abilities
slightly weak or verbal abilities and
then we see a huge gap between they're
very good intellectual skills and
they're adaptive functioning and that is
their social functioning in the day to
day world and then at a very kind of in
a very personal way we see how that
impacts them and here's a quotation from
a response on the ADA's and here the
person is talking about how they think
about friendship and her response was I
realized that it is always a truce
before the official friendship it's very
difficult to explain but I make all the
rules if they follow the rules it will
guide them toward a path of friendship
but people are getting more slippery if
you tell them the rules they follow them
deliberately so it really captures I
mean numerically we capture the
different discrepancy the stark
discrepancy between the person's ability
and their ability to translate that into
the day-to-day functioning in the social
world and then even more poignant Li we
captured the struggles that the person
has in maintaining establishing and
maintaining friendships all right
the cognitive assessment also has some
very practical implications for
diagnosis again in terms of framing the
evaluation let's take for example say we
have we see a child for assessment and
their chronological age is four years
and we assess them and we find out that
their mental age is two years of age and
their social functioning is also at
about the two-year level while their
social functioning is below the
chronological age and may have led
people to think that this is an autism
spectrum disorder the fact that their
social functioning and their mental age
are roughly the same suggests that maybe
this is an intellectual disability so
this is someone who's globally
developmentally delayed rather than if
being autism specific and obviously we
collect more information to make that
determination but this is one example of
how the cognitive evaluation or the
developmental evaluation can help to
frame frame that picture the second
point is very concretely again it can
that cognitive early developmental
evaluations can identify whether there
are any significant developmental delays
so for and this is real important in
terms of making a distinction between
onset criteria for autism versus
Asperger's disorder so whereas in autism
there the onset criteria specified delay
prior to three years of age the opposite
is true an Asperger syndrome so we might
look to that information for helping to
make that differential and then finally
level of cognitive functioning along
with a level of adaptive behavior
informs whether the child has an
intellectual disability and in fact is
part of the definition of an
intellectual disability and then the
last point I want to make here is the
implications is about implications for
intervention the the other aspect of the
ACOG 'native assessment is to identify
strengths and weaknesses in the child's
profile and we use those strengths and
weaknesses to inform intervention and
let me just take you through a few
examples
one is by identifying the child's areas
of weakness or challenge it help can
help to identify some of the goals and
objectives for the child so again let's
take a child who has a chronological age
of eight years but we find upon
assessment that their mental age or the
developmental age is at the two-year
level in that case it gives us some
information about where we set our goals
we want to set our goals and
expectations to meet the child at their
current level of functioning at that
two-year level rather than setting the
goals and expectations at the eight year
level and this is not to minimize or
take away from or reduce our
expectations for that child in the long
run the idea is to try to set the goals
and meet the child where they're at in
order to reduce frustration and help us
work in a systematic way to get at those
higher-order goals another way in which
knowing what the child's strengths and
weaknesses are can be helpful in terms
of questions about the child's
behavioral presentation so sometimes we
might for example get a referring
concern where one of the primary issues
is that the child appears extremely
inattentive and they're not following
through on directions and this is
creating a problem and people are
wondering whether the child has
attention deficit disorder an assessment
might reveal that even though that this
child has really good verbal skills or
expressive language skills that their
verbal comprehension or verbal
understanding is actually quite poor and
so it's this difficulty in verbal
comprehension its difficulty in verbal
understanding that's making them appear
appear inattentive so really they're not
understanding what's being said as
opposed to not being able to attend to
what's being said and then finally
another way in which the assessment can
be helpful in terms of thinking about
our recommendations are is by
identifying what the areas of strengths
are because then we might want to draw
on those strengths to help in the areas
that are weaker so let's say we have a
child who has the opposite profile of
the one I showed you in the slide so now
where their visual processing and their
nonverbal reasoning are really strong
and their verbal skills are very weak we
might want to draw on that strength and
visual processing and use visual
strategies to some more
their communication all right so now I'd
want to turn to just briefly language
and communication assessment in terms of
language and communication assessment
many of the same kinds of principles
that I talked about for the
psychological assessment apply and
because again because difficulties in
communication are one of the central
features of autism spectrum disorders
this becomes a central part of the that
that multidisciplinary assessment so if
you think again back to those three
bubbles one of them was communication so
the communication assessment becomes a
key component of the clinical assessment
overall and this is true for even even
for the higher functioning individuals
with autism and Asperger's disorder who
have a lot of who have language and
maybe even good expressive and receptive
understanding but have significant
problems in how they use language
socially and so the language assessment
is focused on not only the formal
aspects of language so things like
expression and comprehension syntax
grammar and so on but also any a typical
features of communication and the
nonverbal aspects of communication like
individuals prosody the nonverbal forms
of communication how languages used to
interact socially and then also non
literal language so some of the things
in terms of thinking about the this the
atypical features and the prosody some
of the kinds of features that come up
specifically in autism spectrum
disorders are differences in the prosody
of how the person or voice the person
speaks it may be more flat or robotic I
don't know if you wanted to do in a
monotonic voice like this
often very loud so it's not only what
the person is saying but how they're
saying and that becomes an important
relevant part of it the other is
echolalia so whether another feature
that we sometimes see in individuals
with ASD is echolalia so repeating the
same words over and over again and then
finally scripted language so where the
child might have a favorite video like
spur or cartoon like Spongebob and
recite over and again lines or from that
that video alright and just like the
cognitive assessment the communication
assessment typically involves several
components and selection of tests and
assessment procedures depends on the
individual child and their unique
circumstances I'm not going to go into
details about that the types of measures
because I think that will be its own its
own session all right so the next major
area that we look at is adaptive
behavior and adaptive behavior is
actually quite distinct from what we
think about when we're talking about
intellectual ability in addition to the
test of kind of overall development of
tests of intelligence of speech and
language and that we conduct in the
clinic we also want to try to understand
how that child presents in the real
world in more typical settings so not
just in the clinical setting and this
leads us to a concern about adaptive
behavior an attempt to measure that
child's day-to-day functioning in
real-world settings and this is
typically done by through assessment
with the parent and there are also
classroom classroom additions of the
measures as well where the teacher can
report on how the child is doing in the
classroom again this is lending us a
real-world perspective so not only how
can that whether that child can solve a
problem on one of our measures but
whether they can solve a problem in the
real world one of the questions that
comes up is what happens so I said that
IQ intelligence and adaptive behavior
are quite quite distinct so for example
you know in a very concrete way a person
may be able to do multiple advanced
calculations in their head but when they
get to McDonald's and have to order a
hamburger and a coke they have
tremendous difficulty so this kind of
discrepancy is is something that gets
captured all of the time and more often
than not we find that kind of child
intellectual ability is actually greater
than their adaptive skills and when this
was measured in a in a larger group so
these are high functioning individuals
with autism Asperger's syndrome and PDD
all of whom were functioning in the
average range and we're about 12 years
of age
what they found is that overall their
adaptive skills so how they were
functioning in the real world was well
well below their intellectual level and
their interpersonal age equivalent score
was 3.6 years so even though kind of
chronologically they are at the 12 year
they were 12 years old their
intellectual ability was at that 12 year
level how they were functioning in the
day-to-day world was significantly lower
briefly the main measure or a measure
that's often used to capture or to
assess adaptive behaviors of violent
adaptive behavior skills and as you can
see here we're capturing information in
several different domains communication
daily living skills which would include
things like brushing one's teeth bathing
household chores toileting and so on
then socialization motor functioning and
maladaptive behaviors what we find when
you take measurements of again looking
at some of the studies that have been
done in this area when we take measures
of the child's social disability so
their symptom presentation going back
again to those three bubbles so say
we're trying to measure the severity of
symptoms and we're trying to measure how
the person performs in the real world we
find that those two domains are actually
not correlated which is really quite
surprising at first blush so the the
kind of the social disability and the
social abilities are not really are not
significantly correlated and more than
this what we find is that over time
social ability in the ASD group is
negatively correlated with age so as the
kids with ASD get older they're
functioning in the real world declines
whereas their diagnosis or the symptom
presentation right might remor remain a
little more stable this becomes really
important from an intervention
standpoint again because what it means
is we really want to prior to prioritize
adaptive functioning we really want to
be thinking about those real life skills
it's not given that there's this
dissociation between the symptom
presentation and real life functioning
if we were only to focus treatment on
reduction of symptoms
we might not file it may be the case
that that wouldn't necessarily
really lead to any difference in
functioning in the real world so we want
to as much as possible translate the
information that we have into goals for
functioning in at home at school and in
community settings all right just a few
words about assessment of symptoms there
are a number of different rating scales
checklists and other assessment
instruments that have helped us to
capture some of the symptom presentation
and autism spectrum disorders and assist
with diagnosis the two most widely used
at this point in time are the autism
diagnostic interview revised and the
autism diagnostic observation schedule
the ADI are is a means of collecting
historical information as related to ASD
or symptom ASD symptoms and the a dose
is a direct assessment of the child all
of this information is meant to is a
means of kind of structuring and
quantifying our observations but
ultimately we want to integrate that
with informed clinical observation as
well and I'll skip over the details of
the ADI and 8oz sometimes it can be
challenging to distinguish the different
disorders and there are two challenges
that present one is making distinctions
within the class of pervasive
developmental disorders so one part of
differential diagnosis is
differentiating between autism Asperger
disorder and other PD DS and the other
distinction is between PD DS and other
kinds of disorders that might be
presenting such as an intellectual
disability a specific language disorder
and so on so let me just touch upon that
briefly among the pervasive
developmental disorders we have some
very specific criteria for how diagnoses
are made and these include the number
and combination of symptoms and then
also particular onset criteria that
distinguished autism Asperger's
Asperger's disorder and pdd-nos
so we're looking at both the number and
severity of symptoms and we're also
looking at on set in order to make that
distinction from a classification point
of view what's interesting is that in
the literature there's also some
clinical features that seem to
differentiate especially in the higher
functioning individuals high-functioning
individuals with autism and Asperger's
syndrome
now this is still an area that is is is
being discussed in the literature
whether or not these are two distinct
groups of individuals but thus far there
are certain features that have been
identified that seemed to be more
characteristic of individuals with
high-functioning autism and asperger
disorder and just to give you some
examples in each of those domains so for
example one feature clinical feature
that seems to present more frequently in
high-functioning autism is in terms of
social interaction is greater social
isolation a more aloof presentation or a
more passive presentation when
interacting with others whereas an
Asperger's syndrome often there's
greater social approach and although and
the person appears very interested in
others although the initiations might be
very awkward from a communication
standpoint just highlighting a couple of
things in autism we might see that more
characteristic monotone speech pattern
that dr. volkmar demonstrated or we
might see a history of absent or delayed
language an Asperger's disorder by
definition early language skills are
preserved and what we tend to see is
more verbosity where the person is
talking at you almost in a professorial
pedantic way another feature in the
behaviors category that distinct
clinical feature that sometimes can
distinguish individuals the
high-functioning autism Asperger's
syndrome is a type of interest so in
autism we might see some some narrow
interests or some splinter skills so
some very isolated ability area such as
somebody who has excellent drawing
skills for example and can reproduce a
drawing in extreme and perfect detail an
Asperger's disorder what we tend to see
is some narrow circumscribed interests
that are all absorbing and that tend to
be the amassing of information about
that particular topic
and I'm kind of a debt kind of a
dedication to thinking about and
acquiring information on that subject
area
all right the other area so that one
area of differential diagnosis is within
the PD D spectrum that other area that
were sometimes faced with in terms of
differential diagnosis is thinking about
other disorders that might be presenting
rather than an autism spectrum disorder
and these include again intellectual
disability language disorders
obsessive-compulsive disorder
schizophrenia and so on and some of that
you know for each of these that how we
make the distinction is more complex
than what I'm about to say but some here
are some of the things that we might
look at so for example in an
intellectual disability we might expect
to see a pattern of more even
development so where the person's
language their social functioning their
overall cognitive ability is more even
it might all be delayed relative to the
person's cognitive well relative to the
person's chronological age but we
wouldn't see necessarily those marked
discrepancies and that we do see in
pervasive developmental disorders in
language disorders one of the things
that we might see that distinguishes a
child from a child with autism spectrum
disorder is the use of nonverbal
communication to compensate for the
language impairment so whereas in
individuals with ASD both verbal and
nonverbal communication can be impaired
in terms of social interaction what we
might find is for a child with a
language disorder they might have
difficulty expressing themselves but
then use nonverbal acts to get your
attention for example by tapping you on
the shoulder to get your attention or
using eye contact to draw you in or
pointing to draw your attention to
something that's enter interest and so
using those nonverbal means to draw the
person in and to elicit that social
interaction even in the absence of
having access to language an
obsessive-compulsive disorder and
obsessive-compulsive disorder
individuals were so a number of
obsessions and compulsions but there are
those compulsions tend to be experienced
as a source of distress whereas what we
find for individuals with Asperger
syndrome for example who do
have a particular interest and it can be
obsessive in the sense that it's
something that occupies their thinking
and occupies their time to a great
extent what we find is that that's
actually a preferred activity something
that's sought out and so on so these are
some of the ways in which we think about
the differentials all right so I've
touched on some domains what I haven't
had a chance to go into more detail
about but our other areas of assessment
that are equally important and can would
complement all of the different areas
that I've just talked about in this
session and that includes behavioral
observations across these different
settings behavioral assessment
neuropsychological assessment
occupational therapy and physical
therapy assessment assessment of child's
academic skills medical and vocational
and so on all right and so to wrap up
just want to go over the main takeaway
points from this session so first of all
the importance of assessment the main
assessment is about one component of
assessment as we talked about is
diagnosis it's just one part of the
assessment process and there we're
looking at a constellation of features
that hang together and represent a
particular diagnostic category it's not
the whole story but it's important part
of the story and one reason it can be
important is because it gains allows a
person to gain access to services and
here I've given you a few examples so
that can be access to services at the in
the school in terms of idea categories
and a label of autism it can be access
to government agencies such as the
Department of Developmental Services
which was formerly the department of
mental retardation it can also direct
the person to government resources
national resources and community
resources that could be quite helpful
and then more broadly thinking about
diagnosis and assessment as that first
step toward developing a treatment plan
for the child by identifying what their
strengths and weaknesses are and
developing goals from that in terms of
the assessment process just a brief
overview it involves taking taking a
thorough history establishing what the
child's developmental cognitive and
language baseline are assess
in assessing symptoms of autism
assessing adaptive functioning looking
at any medical issues in comorbidity
assessing sensory and motor functioning
and then again as needed doing more
comprehensive neuropsychological
assessment looking at academic skills
vocational skills and so on and then the
fine final points in terms of the main
issues in assessment of ASD and what
actually I think actually makes it a
really interesting group of children to
work with is the very levels of
functioning that can present the very
profiles of functioning thinking back to
those strengths and weaknesses or highs
and lows in the profile the idea that
performance can vary across across
different kinds of settings and can even
vary over time and so this leads us to
this idea that the assessment of ASD
should be ideally comprehensive and
involve multiple disciplines measures of
the person's ability and disability and
collection of information across people
in context and finally ultimately what
we hope as part of this process when
we're doing when we're operating as a
multidisciplinary team and conducting
the evaluation is we want to try to
present a single coherent view of this
child and we try as much as possible to
be in close communication with each
other to avoid fragmentation and be able
to provide this cohesive view that we
can then communicate to the parents to
other to the school and other providers
in this child's life and then also and
then finally draw this take our
assessment results and think about those
implications for adaptation and learning
and ultimately for the child's treatment
goals alright just in time through thank
you